hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem valid sudoku and
i'm going to be recording this on the
4th of july so hopefully there aren't
too many firework noises in the
background so we are given a 9x9 sudoku
board and all we want to do is determine
if the board in its current state is
valid or not
and they tell us only the filled in
cells need to be validated according to
the three rules of sudoku so basically
each row must only contain digits
between 1 through 9 without repetition
the same is true for every single column
in this board it can only contain digits
1 through nine without repetition that
means we can't have duplicates in any
particular row or any particular column
and the third part which is going to be
the most tricky is each three by three
sub box basically you know you can kind
of see it in the drawing right three by
this entire nine by nine grid is made up
of nine three by three grids right
there's one here one here one here and
you know basically nine of them as you
can see so basically for each of these
three by three
sub grids we also want to check that it
only contains digits one through nine
without repetition basically without
repetition that means it has to contain
every single digit from one through nine
now of course the sudoku board doesn't
necessarily have to be filled in you can
see this 3x3 is not filled in but in
this case we are going to say ok this
this one is valid because it you know it
only has a 6 and it doesn't have any
duplicates right but we do we don't only
have to check each 3x3 grid we also have
to check every single column and every
single row now before i get into the
solution let me just very quickly
clarify what this problem wants from us
you might over complicate it and think
something like this what if we had a row
such as this one it has one two three
four five six seven eight that must mean
even though this spot is empty that must
mean a nine has to go here right that's
pretty obvious but take a look at this
column it has two three four five six
seven eight nine that must mean that the
value that goes here has to be a one so
we have a contradiction we have to
either put a 1 or a 9 but we know that
both need to be in this position so in
this case this is not a valid sudoku
board right well that's technically true
but for this problem we are going to
consider this board yes it's valid
because
as of right now based on what the cells
are filled in like what cells are filled
in there aren't any contradictions we're
not going to assume anything for any of
these empty positions even though we
know for sure yes a 9 would have to go
here based on this row we're not going
to assume that so it's actually a little
bit easier than you might think so the
algorithm is going to be pretty standard
right we're going to go through every
single row and make sure every
particular row does not have any
duplicates how could we do that we could
do it a bunch of different ways but i'm
going to do a hash set right so a hash
set will be easy for us to detect if
there are any duplicates so we're going
to have a unique hash set for every
single row in the entire grid right so
then we can easily determine if any
particular row has any filled in
duplicates right this row obviously
doesn't a five a three and a seven no
duplicates right so that portion is
pretty easy right number one is pretty
easy to check what about number two
checking each column we can do the exact
same thing just have a hash set for
every single column right every single
column has a hash set and then we can
determine if there are any duplicates or
not right and for you know adding an
element to the hash set is of one
checking duplicates is also o of one so
so far we have a time complexity for
just checking the columns and the rows
we have a time complexity which is
basically the size of the entire grid
which is nine squared pretty much now
the last part in theory should also be
pretty easy but coding it up is a little
bit more tricky there are many ways to
do it i'm going to show you the easiest
way we want to be able to tell okay for
every three by three grid which there
are nine of does any of them have any
duplicates so again we can use a hash
set to represent each of these three by
three grids but the question is how are
we gonna do it how can it be easy to
code something like that and that's what
i'm gonna quickly explain to you right
now and after i do we can jump into the
code the overall solution is yes though
going to be o of n 9 squared we're
pretty much just going to have to
iterate through over the entire grid and
nothing else but we are going to have
extra space also of 9 squared because
we're going to have three hash sets
which are going to be this exact size so
roughly this is the memory complexity as
well so we want to represent each of
these three by three grids with a hash
set but how do we know if we're at any
particular value right like i have
labeled the indices right this is going
to represent what row this is going to
represent which column how do we know if
we're if any particular value such as 1
1 happens to be in this 3 by three grid
whereas a different
cell such as four four happens to be in
this three by three grid how can we
differentiate them
notice how each of these three by three
sub squares happens to be three by three
right so one way is to basically make it
so that we can
have an index right so maybe zero
represents this row of of the three
different squares right and a 1
represents this row of 3 squares and a 2
represents a row of this right and
similarly for the columns right a 0 over
here represents this column a 1 over
here represents this column and a 2 over
here represents this column then if we
had two indices right if we can somehow
take 4 4 and convert it to 1
1 then we know it goes inside this sub
square right so basically we have nine
different sub squares we're gonna have
indices to represent them right a one
one means that this is the sub square
that we're talking about right this one
and the way the math is going to work
out is since each of these is three by
three we can just take the actual index
such as four let's say we were given
four four right this is the square we're
talking about we can take four which is
the row divide it by three integer
division right we're talking about
integer division 4 divided by 3 is going
to give us a 1. similarly we do the same
thing with the column right 4 divided by
3 is going to give us a 1. right so if
we take the actual coordinates 4 4
divide the coordinates integer division
by three then we get the index for the
row column and it basically identifies
which square this is a part of now let's
just check that the edge cases work out
let's try a8 right this is the boundary
what happens if we take 8 divided by 3
and 8 divided by 3 right well then we
get 2 2 right integer division we always
round down 2 2 that works out for us
right let's do a different edge case
maybe we try this this square right on
the boundary does this
does this identify zero zero because
that's what it should well let's take
the positions the indices two two divide
them by three two divided by three two
divided by three we round these down so
we get 0 0 that does uniquely identify
or it you know correctly identifies that
it belongs to this 3x3 grid so that's
kind of how we're going to identify when
we go through every position every cell
in the entire sudoku board which of the
three which of the three by three uh
grids is it a part of and then we can
and then we can add them to that right
so we're gonna have a hash set where the
key of the hash set is going to be a
pair of values the row column not the
actual row column right but the you know
when we convert it to the row column
basically row divided by three and
column divided by three that's what the
key of the hash hashmap is going to be
and the value is similarly going to be a
hash set where we can tell do we have
any duplicates in this 3x3 grid or not
right same for every single 3x3 grid
we're just checking does it have any
duplicates if not then we can continue
if it does have a duplicate that means
our sudoku board is not valid and then
we would have to return false but if it
is valid we're just going to continue so
we're basically going to go over the
entire grid right every single uh
position in the entire grid if we find
any duplicates we return false if we
don't at the end we can return true so
now we have enough information to
actually write out the code so let's do
that okay so now we can write the code
like i mentioned i'm going to be
detecting duplicates with a hash set but
you could do it with arrays if you
wanted to as well because we know the
dimensions of this sudoku board it's
nine by nine but i'm going to be using a
hash set or dictionary just because it's
easier so
in this case i'm actually using a hash
map where the uh key is just going is
going to be the column number and the
value is going to be another set
basically the set is going to represent
all particular values in this column and
we're going to do the same thing for
rows this is only so we can detect
duplicates so let's create another
uh hash map
with rows and another hash map with the
squares and remember the key for the
squares is going to be a pair of values
basically the row divided by three and
the
column divided by three so now we just
want to iterate over the entire grid
and we know the dimensions are nine by
nine so i'm just going to hard code that
in to these loops and so we know that a
position in the sudoku board actually
could be empty and they tell us that an
empty position is represented by a dot
so the first thing we're going to check
is if this is an empty space then we can
just skip it right then we're just going
to continue to the next iteration of the
loop the next thing we want to check is
have we found a duplicate because if we
have then we return false immediately so
we want to know does this this uh value
if it's not empty it has it already been
detected so if the board is in
rows at this current row what does this
mean we're saying okay the current row
that we're in
basically this is our hash map right
rows is our hash map the key we're
putting in is the current row that we're
in so that's so this basically
represents a hash set as you can see up
above a set a hash set of all values
that occur in this particular row number
so if so so basically if this uh this
current number that we're at is already
inside the current row meaning we've
already seen this value before in the
current row that we're in that means
it's a duplicate right in which case we
can return false but that's not it
basically the exact same thing is going
to be true
if this value has already occurred in
the same column before so we're going to
change this to columns at the current
column that we're at so if this value
has already occurred in the current
column then we're in that we're in that
means we've detected another duplicate
in which case we can return false and
last but not least we have to check if
this value has already occurred in the
current square that we're in before so
how do we get the current square that
we're in uh right now well
we we know the key for that is going to
be a pair of values basically as i wrote
above rho divided by three and column
divided by three so that tells us the
current square that we're in and this
will return a set as you can see up
above of all the values that we have
seen in the current square before and if
this value that we're at right now is a
duplicate that means it's already going
to be in this this hash set in which
case we can also return false so this is
basically our way of validating that
this current sudoku board is valid if we
have any duplicates that means it's not
valid we return false if it is valid we
continue and we basically update all
three of our hash maps up above so
columns of the current column we're
going to add to it the current character
that we just saw and we're going to do
the same thing with the current row that
we're in and we're going to do the exact
same thing with the current square that
we're in of course this has a pair of
values as the key so this makes sure
that our hash sets are updated and we'll
make sure to detect any duplicates when
we get to the next iteration of the
loops so in this way we're iterating
over the entire board and if we never
detect any duplicates then we can
outside of the loop just return true
that means the current sudoku board with
the current values populated and it is
valid as you can see the solution runs
and is pretty efficient so i hope this
was helpful this is one of the easier
ways the more neat ways of writing this
code of course there are some more
complex ways as well but i think this is
fairly readable and the main you know
the trick that we use is just this whole
row divided by three column divided by
three which just makes the code a lot
easier in my opinion so i hope that this
was helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching